Diane is with us to start off this hour
in New Mexico hi Diane how are you hi
Dave thank you for taking my call it's
an honor to talk to you you too
what's up okay I have a four month
emergency fund the only dead I have is
my house and I have a Roth 401k and I
called my financial advisor to try to
kind of look for the future and just
kind of try to get things started with
this now I only have a measly eleven
thousand dollars in there and so he told
me my financial advisor told me that he
took it off the market and he it so
right now it's just sitting in cash and
he took it off the market because he was
unsure about the economy and how did he
do that without your permission
um well this was in January he said he
was going to do it I guess I didn't know
what that meant either so and he said he
did say it was only going to be for a
very short time and this was in January
so now it's dune
so he's but yeah so your financial
advisors job is to advise you not to
make your decisions for you okay and the
only way they advise you is if you know
what you're doing and that means that
your financial advisors other job is to
teach you and so I think you need a new
financial advisor I was I was kind of
thinking that because I want someone
with the heart of a teacher because
Diane you're in charge of this money and
it's not measly if you send it to me
I'll keep it it's a lot of money yeah I
mean you worked hard for it
yeah and so you need to know what you're
putting money into and then if someone
who's advising me gives me advice about
something I understand because I
wouldn't be invested in something I
didn't understand to start with and then
I need to understand I want to question
them about the advice that they're
giving me and I'm going to Beit based on
the advice they give me I'm going to
then make my decision about my money
that God gave
to manage he didn't give it to that guy
to manage and and I don't like the fact
that it sounds like he's doing whatever
he wants with this money without your
permission or you've signed a you've
signed an account signed up for an
account that allows him to trade on your
behalf and I don't want that I want I
want the money only moved when you say
it's moved and only then after you
understand why it would be moved hey
here's the thing it sounds like he's
trying to time the market meaning he
thinks the markets going to go down so
he pulls the money out yeah he thinks
the markets going to go up so he puts
the money in there's all kinds of
research and data that shows that that
approach to investing does not work okay
because if he was so dadgum smart he
could he knew exactly what the stock
market was going to do go up or down
he'd be running a billion dollar fund in
New York he wouldn't be sitting there
being your advisor yeah okay you know
cuz nobody knows is my point I know a
ton about it but I don't know when the
markets going to go down or when the
market is going to go up you know when I
invest every single month whether it
goes down or whether it goes up I put
money in the market every single month
whether it goes down whether it goes up
I quit trying to figure out when it's
going to go up or going to go down
because there's a lot of research that
shows market timing will cause you to
lose your tail end so I think you need a
new advisor someone that's going to
teach you and I think you need to raise
your confidence level with having
learned in yourself to be able to make
some choices with the help of someone
showing you some things and teaching you
some things and that's what I would do
if I were in your shoes and if you need
some help with that you're one of our
endorsed local providers our LPS for
investing you can go to Dave Ramsey comm
and click on those and I click on
investing and it'll show you who we
recommend in that area and they will
take small accounts the size of yours
otherwise they won't get my endorsement
so we and they have the heart of a
teacher or they don't get my endorsement
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
so you have to break the cycle you have
to flip this thing on its head and make
it behave you've got to get so fired up
and wired up that you're broke friends
think you've lost your mind